les négociations de paix qui ont été
mises à mal par les affrontements entre
israël et le hezbollah au sud liban
après sept jours d'attaquer clair le
point de la situation charles enderlin
près l'accord de cessez-le-feu au liban
le chef d'état major israélien n'avait
que des compliments four
le président assad c'est un leader
sérieux capable très habile elle sert
bien les intérêts de son pays qui
d'ailleurs ne s'oppose pas toujours aux
nôtres un ton qui réflète la
satisfaction des dirigeants israéliens
il estime que grâce à la décision
syrienne d'accepter les propositions
américaines
la carte politique du liban est en train
de changer le res bola devrait être
pratiquement désarmés et le calme
revenir des deux côtés de la frontière
des chars israéliens quitte le liban et
en galilée c'est le retour à la normale
mais la crise au sud liban à relancer
l'agitation dans les territoires occupés
où les intégristes palestiniens ont pris
fait et cause pour le res bola libanais
au nom de la solidarité islamique
il n'y aura pas de cessez le feu à gaza
ce matin un militant du jihad islamique
a détourné un autobus pour heurter de
plein fouet ces voitures de
l'administration israélienne
il y à un mort et cinq blessés un des
chefs de l'épée de l'islam la branche
militaire du jihad islamique menace nous
vengerons l'attaquent contrôleur reste
ball là nous avons un ennemi commun et
nous détruirons son état la cisjordanie
et gaza seront la tombe des colons juifs
il est en tête de liste des palestiniens
recherchés par l'armée israélienne
pour la première fois depuis plusieurs
mois des militants armés ont fait leur
apparition ces derniers jours dans des
manifestations à gaza